joining us now is stephen miller former
senior adviser to president trump
founder of america first legal stephen
without
taking
accountability here having any
accountability for their own actions
they're going to continue to inflict
pain on the american people by not
enforcing our border period and they're
blaming now the end of covid policies
well it's an entirely voluntary and
deliberate choice on their part which is
what makes it all the more outrageous
president trump put into place a series
of policies to ensure swift border
returns and deportations
at the center piece of that in 2020 was
this authority title 42 the
administration is voluntarily planning
to rip out this policy and to let even
more millions of illegal immigrants into
the country and they cannot blame russia
or vladimir putin or anybody else for
this they are willfully destroying our
border because they want to
well the white house sent fox a
statement about the border tonight the
administration is doing our due
diligence to prepare for potential
changes at the border
that is good government in action this
administration is working every day to
restore order fairness and humanity to
our immigration system
stephen good government apparently means
open borders
they are
they are in the process right now just
to be clear of figuring out how they can
get all of the illegal aliens who will
be arriving into a city near you as
quickly as possible that is the only
planning that is taking place in the
white house and at dhs is they're going
to find volunteers and non-governmental
organizations and federal workers to
take the illegal immigrants and put them
to pennsylvania and bring them to ohio
and bring them to wisconsin and bring
them to indiana and every other state in
the country that is the only planning
they are doing but they speak to the
american people like we are fools like
we are idiots like we can't see what's
happening in front of our own eyes it's
propaganda but it's cheap pathetic
propaganda at that
so putin's solely to blame really for
rising gas prices
and the end of covid
is to blame for the border
it's just spring it's spring's fault
it's the weather's fault really it's
it's the position of the planet in
relation to the sun that's ultimately
who's to blame here but when the ukraine
story as obviously critically important
as it is and it is important
do you notice how the border reporting
is just kind of faded into the
background stephen it's only our country
no big deal well it's not it's not by
accident i mean the administration is
doing a truly horrendous job in europe
they knew for months in advance about
the invasion their strategy was a
catastrophic failure but yet but yet it
cannot be denied that they are talking
endlessly about ukraine and only ukraine
because if nothing else it provides a
chance to take focus off of our own
southern border which let's not forget
there is a narco war happening on the
other side of that border there are
hundreds of thousands of americans being
killed by drugs many more on top of that
are also being killed by gang members
coming across that border it's our
country we should care about it we
should talk about it well maybe mitt
romney might mention that once in a
while stephen thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else